e
le massif du tarn hausses entrecoupées
de forêts de plaine est l'un des plus
anciens d'allemagne sa formation est
antérieure à celle des alpes durant des
milliers d'années les peuples et les
cultures se sont succédé dans la région
l'enrichissant chaque fois un peu plus
les rumeurs ou introduit ce qu'ils sont
devenus les emblèmes culinaire de la s
l'un évoque l'automne et l'enfance
l'autre est le fruit originelle la
châtaigne et la pomme se décline à
l'envi dans les spécialités
gastronomiques de cette région
d'allemagne que nous vous proposons
aujourd'hui de découvrir
nous nous rendrons dans le village de
quelque am traverseront koenig stein
kronberg robert rosen pour enfin arriver
à rudan derval
en route pour le tas ou mousse dans
l'ouest de l'allemagne pour un voyage le
long de la route du cidre et des vergers
de s
un après midi ensoleillé un verger
paisible et opulent des arbres chargés
de fruits bien mûrs qui s'offre à notre
gourmandise
est ce le paradis pas tout à fait mais
presque
nous voici à quelqu'un hors now la
petite entreprise familiale de heinz
bender y cultive des pommes depuis sept
générations
la culture des pommiers demande une
attention de tous les instants
surtout quand ils sont en pleine
croissance pas question de laisser
divaguer les jeunes pousses et ma vie de
tout
le verger goûte plus de 1200 pommier 14
variétés de pommes s'épanouissent dans
ce jardin d'éden
comme un fruit défendu pas pour wolfgang
le frère de heinz qui n'a pas son pareil
pour accommoder ses fruits dans leur
restaurant gastao stone south la pomme
fruit ancestrales se prête à toutes les
fantaisies culinaires
voici un plat qui ne manque pas de
piquant aux pommes volcan wendel ajoute
des poivrons des concombres et une purée
d'ail
on fait d'abord revenir les légumes dans
du beurre on ajoute du bouillon on
laisse mijoter puis la soupe enix et
volcans réinvente sans cesse la cuisine
traditionnelle et c'hoazh et remet au
goût du jour de vivre cette le succès
des frères bender des plaintes terroir
d'un grand raffinement
à la belle saison ils organisent des
dégustations à l'ombre des pommiers
heinz marie avec bonheur les différentes
variétés qui pousse dans son verger
c'est ainsi qu'il obtient un cidre aux
arômes subtils bien équilibrée gouleyant
fruité et sympathique comme il aime à
dire comme la récolte est différente
d'une année à l'autre
le cidre des frères bender n'est jamais
tout à fait le même
mais au fait où en est notre gaspacho
les soirs
c'est mieux fatah
quand la méditerranée s'invite dans le
terroir allemand
chez les frères bender on l'aura compris
la pomme et rem soupe de pommes glace à
la pomme mêmes sindou à la pomme autant
de variations sur un même thème qui
ravissent les clients du restaurant le
gaspacho de wolf gang est un véritable
succès et pour joindre l'utile à
l'agréable pourquoi pas un peu de
lecture sur les illustres habitants de
la région
les frères bender perpétue la tradition
familiale avec passion et talent de quoi
rendre fier toute la galerie des
ancêtres leur restaurant est une des
adresses les plus prisées des environs
il est temps pour nous de reprendre
notre périple à travers le cas où nous
nous retournons sur la route du cidre
vers de nouvelles découvertes
le trajet est un véritable enchantement
prochaine étape que nick stein
cette petite station climatique abrite
un trésor des plus savoureux que neil
stein ou plus précisément la commune de
molsheim qui lui est rattachée n'est
rien moins que la capitale allemande de
la châtaigne
au café restaurant de soudaines
fonctions elle entre dans la préparation
de nombreux plats depuis la terrasse du
restaurant la vue sur le bosquet de
châtaignier est magnifique
par beau temps on peut même apercevoir
francfort sur le main
au menu du jour velouté de châtaignes
suivi d'un ragoût de sangliers
accompagné de connell de pommes de terre
et de châtaignes confites
pour le chef dirk fuchs ce fruit
d'automne aux qualités nutritives
exceptionnelles est une source
d'inspiration sans cesse renouvelé
aujourd'hui ils confectionnent des
chocolats à la châtaigne est caramélisée
fourrée d'une crème à la liqueur de
châtaignes la préparation de ces petites
douceurs demande un certain doigté et
surtout un ingrédient des plus précieux
du temps
pourquoi termites ce sera la cerise 6
est un plaisir éphémère cependant les
chocolats sont prêts place à la
dégustation
dirk fuchs a invité quelques amis à qui
il a réservé la primeur de sa nouvelle
création entre molsheim des kronberg
s'étend la plus grande châtaigneraie du
nord des alpes
à propos petite leçon de choses
quelle est la différence entre la
châtaigne et le marron la châtaigne est
issu du châtaignier sauvages alors que
le marron comestibles provient du
châtaignier qui a été greffé dans le but
d'être cultivé
gare à ne pas les confondre avec le
fruit non comestibles du marronnier
d'inde qui ornent nos allées ce sont les
romains qui ont introduit les
châtaigniers en europe des arbres qui
peuvent atteindre l'âge de deux cents
ans ironise schiesser et membre de
l'association pour la préservation des
châtaigniers de molsheim
le marché de la pomme et de la châtaigne
est l'occasion pour l'association de
faire la promotion de ses richesses
locales
et de sensibiliser la population à la
nécessité de prendre soin de ce
patrimoine
le bois de châtaignier mérite également
toutes les attentions
il est particulièrement souple et facile
à travailler et se plie à tous les
caprices
le marché de la pomme et de la châtaigne
est un événement phare dans la région du
tas où nous nous retrouvons dirk fuchs
ses chocolats aux châtaignes
caramélisées font un malheur
sur cette note sucrée nous poursuivons
notre route avec la métropole d'humains
en toile de fond quelques coups de
pédales plus loin nous arrivons à
kronberg petite ville thermale niché
dans un écrin de verdure où nous attend
une adresse des plus aristocratique
kronberg abrite l'imposant château de
friedrich strophes construit entre 1889
et 1894 il s'agit de la dernière
résidence de l'impératrice douairière
victoria de plus à la mort de son époux
l'empereur frédéric iii
elle refuse de rester à la cour mais ne
conçoit pas non plus de retourner en
angleterre
au grand regret de son fils est empereur
guillaume 2 peu appréciée par la cour
décrié pour ses idées libérales
l'impératrice frédéric comme on la
surnommait était une femme sûre d'elle
et prise d'art et de littérature
aujourd'hui le château est devenu un
hôtel de luxe qui n'a rien perdu de son
faste et de sa splendeur impérial dans
le salon bleu où l'impératrice recevait
l'aristocratie européenne
on célèbre désormais des mariages les
pièces sont extraordinairement bien
préserver l'histoire avec un grand h est
à portée de main
une partie du mobilier des oeuvres d'art
qu'abrite le château qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui schlosshotel kronberg font
partie des collections de l'impératrice
douairière
oliver près ding est le chef du
restaurant de l'hôtel pour lui la
simplicité et le maître mot en cuisine
et déteste par dessus tout les
fioritures inutiles ces assiettes sont
tout en sobriété et raffinement
ce lieu historique l'inspirent et il
tient à lui rendre hommage dans chacune
de ses créations
mais il sait également distillé avec
habilité des notes plus moderne plus
exotiques comme dans ce plat qui réunit
l'asie et la méditerranée
au menu du jour celle de chevreuil en
coûte des pistes confite en
accompagnement des champignons du chou
frisé à la truffe et des pommes
dauphines
le tout agrémenté de quelques copeaux de
truffe
pour oliver le repas doit être une
véritable célébration l'enthousiasmé du
jeune chef a fait souffler un vent de
fraîcheur au château les clients de
l'hôtel sont contre
après les agapes quoi de mieux qu'une
petite promenade digestive dans le parc
du château
une partie des jardins du palais a été
transformée en jardin public
une statue de l'empereur frédéric iii et
accueille le visiteur
maintenant un autre voyage dans le temps
nous attend
devant nous c'est en une forêt digne
d'un conte de fées un endroit où l'homme
semble pénétré pour la première fois
nous sommes en contrebas de la chronique
un des plus hauts sommets du tas ou
mousse
on
c'est ici qu'a émergé la première
grandes métropoles de la région ram
l'une des plus importantes colonies
celte d'europe
le mur blanc un talus d'éboulis composé
de quartzite dutau nous ce qui
s'illumine au moindre rayon de soleil
est une des particularités géologiques
du site
les amoureux de la civilisation celte ne
peuvent s'empêcher de ressentir une
vibration particulière émanant de ces
lieux
d'autres plus pragmatiques y verront
simplement un vestige de l'âge de glace
nous marchons en direction du monde
remark le long de l'ourthe barre ce
charmant petit ruisseau nous emmène vers
notre prochaine étape culinaire à
travers le massif du tarnos oberhausen
au nord ouest de francfort sur le main
ici le vin de pomme fait également
partie de la tradition
tout comme ces jolies maisons à
colombages
nous ne résistons pas à un petit tour au
marché place de l'hôtel de ville le
samedi
les produits régionaux sont à l'honneur
nous avons donné rendez vous aux chefs
bertl ébacher devant l'étal de pom and
autrichien haut en couleurs récompensé à
plusieurs reprises pour l'excellence de
sa cuisine acidulées ferme et juteuse
voilà les trois qualités que doit réunir
une pomme si elle veut avoir l'honneur
de finir au showdown kraftwerk
c'est le nom du restaurant de bertone et
barreur il s'agit de l'ancienne centrale
électrique d'oberhausen
classé monument historique merten
ébacher est un chef passionné et
généreux
à l'image de sa déclinaison du mendiant
et comme plat principal un rôti de boeuf
à la tate auf der hot dance quantifie le
ch les boues ne paraît producteurs ont
enchaîné un déficit fiscal quand marine
autorité style de boxe boxe
professionnelle riche on promet de
grands moments importants
aly cissokho est consacré à pizza et au
mobilier de la casnos situation instable
nous générons des coups de semonce
mortes at-il parfois le mal du pays
le père gay ces 500 euros
le talent et la virtuosité de berthen
ébacher ne sont pas passés inaperçus
dans la région en 2010 notamment son
restaurant s'est distingué lors du grand
prix de la gastronomie de s il a obtenu
la première place dans la catégorie
cuisine noble le kraftwerk compte de
nombreux habitués qui apprécient la
finesse de la cuisine de bertone et
barreur
le chef propose également un très grand
choix de vins autrichien souvent mal
connu mais qui brillent par leur qualité
leur variété et leur identité unique le
kraftwerk ou l'histoire d'une
reconversion réussie
et pour compléter le tableau il est
client ont également droit à une vue sur
les vieilles dames de l'atelier de
restauration automobile située juste à
côté une atmosphère industriels et rétro
pour une cuisine moderne et raffiné
à présent direction le nord de bad
homburg où nous attend une curiosité
archéologique de taille le fort de la
zale bourgue est le seul formule iter
romain entièrement reconstituée au monde
mais avant de plonger dans la vie
romaine un petit détour dans la ville
thermale de bad en bourse s'impose
le château de bad hombourg était la
résidence du land grave de s on bourre
la tour blanche une des tours du donjon
du 14e siècle est aujourd'hui l'emblème
de la ville depuis bad homburg en route
pour une découverte de la vie romaine au
fort de la zale bourgue le visiteur peut
se faire une idée du quotidien des 600
soldats de l'empiré romain
c'est l'empereur guillaume qui fut à
l'initiative de sa reconstruction en
à l'époque la promiscuité était grande
huit soldats se partager une chambre et
qui savait aussi de cuisine ils se
chargent eux-mêmes de leur repas ils
cuisent est leur pain et disposer même
de leur propre mela grain le musée
présente les découvertes archéologiques
dans une mise en scène très pédagogique
le site a été inscrit en 2005 sur la
liste du patrimoine mondial de l'unesco
le pr manager
un des points forts de la visite le
réfectoire des officiers avec ses
fresques originale d'une beauté à couper
le souffle
qu'en est il des fameuses orgies
romaines à la taberna le restaurant du
musée
nous tentons d'en savoir un peu plus ça
me bâtir y prépare une fricassée de
champignons à partir d'une recette
traditionnelle du miel avec des
champignons la taberna propose tous les
jours cet appétissant de fricassée de
champignons ainsi que d'autres délices
gastronomiques du temps des romains des
oeufs étaient souvent proposé en
ouverture du repas des pommes venait
clore les réjouissances
notre dernière étape au monde nous
attend
non loin de roda nerval au beau milieu
de la forêt se trouve une petite ferme
auberge plein de charme
leichel barreur bof
une adresse authentique entre terroir et
tradition ici pia schmitt grossman
réaliser son rêve
veaux vaches cochons couvées c'est son
idée du bonheur même si le travail est
parfois difficile à la ferme
elle ne renoncerait pour rien au monde à
cette vie au grand air simple et
vivifiante
elle accorde une grande importance au
bien-être de ces animaux même si leur
destin est de finir dans la casserole
pia se destinait pourtant métier de
clerc de notaire
pourquoi un tel changement de cap
et si en plus elle peut partager sa
passion avec les randonneurs de passage
et leur faire déguster ses produits
elle est au paradis le holà pommes de
terre sautées en rôti de boeuf et
connell de pomme de terre fait maison la
cuisine de pia et rustique et généreuse
pia a choisi elle même chaque meuble du
restaurant qu'elle a chinés dans les
brocantes et les magasins d'antiquités
les environs c'est dans une atmosphère
pleine de convivialité que ses clients
dégustent ces délicieuses spécialités
arrosées de cidre fait maison
serait-elle une restauratrice dans l'âme
et elle peut aussi compter sur le
soutien de toute sa famille tout le
monde met la main à la pâte
le resteront de l'école d'art of est
ouvert trois fois par semaine le
mercredi et le week end
qu'on se le dise c'est ici que s'achève
notre voyage une balade gourmande
culturel et chargé d'histoire à travers
la région du tas où nous le long de la
route du cidre et des vergers de s
pour